okay so plus-size model Abby Bible
showcased her sexy date night outfit
let's pull it up so plus-size model Abby
Bible known for her confidence and style
recently wowed her 60,000 Instagram
followers with a a sexy date night
outfit she dawned a backless cutout crop
top that exposed her back and cleavage
flaunting her size 22
figure her fans praised her for the a
stunning look showcasing herself
self-proclaimed Unapologetic fat girl
attitude in a series of alluring photos
she confidently posed and even revealed
a tattoo oh a tattoo on her chest oh a
chest tattoo let's let's
see wow no the back
flabs I don't understand why can't you
just wear a flowy dress like the rest of
the fat chicks why do you
oh why do they why do they cheer this on
this is so sad this is
oh God the blubber I don't want to see
it
anymore put that away put that can we
please stop
don't guys why do women lead each other
to destruction you don't look good chica
it's time to get on the treadmill start
running please put it away please please
please wear a flowy outfit and please
stop making me cover this
because I I just read the news here the
body positive people actually I would
argue are body negative because they
only praise bodies that are unhealthy
where is the praise for healthy bodies
and I'm talking actual healthy bodies
not women that claim they have thyroid
issues and are 300 bajillion pounds um
but the actual thin inshape healthy
looking chicks and the truth
is that you will only find them
glorifying obesity so let me know what
you guys want me to cover next time on
Pearl daily make sure you like the video
on your way out and subscribe and get
yourself a women shouldn't vote t-shirt
today I will talk to you guys next
time